Speaker 1: Here's something funny to wrap
today.
Up yesterday was former President Donald Trump.
Seventy fifth birthday.
He celebrated, of course, like anyone else
at one of his own clubs, wearing a suit with
all the other men wearing suits and everybody
referring to him as Sir and Mr. President,
there's nothing more heartwarming and convivial
and familiar than getting people to wear suits
and say Happy birthday, sir, Mr. President.
And it really looks like a hostage video.
I have to show you this.
When when they're singing him happy birthday.
This looks like when all the parents tell
their kids, I don't care if you don't like
little Donny, you have to go to the party
and you've got to behave because his parents
are important people and I'm not going to
be embarrassed.
Check this out.
Unidentified: Oh.
I mean.
Speaker 2: Better than.
Speaker 1: Happy birthday, dear Mr. President.
That's a real family and friends gathering
up.
Did you hear that and if you don't run again,
we are going to sing to you every year.
What would you tell Donald Trump on his seventy
fifth birthday?
Well, what Newsmax did is send a guy with
a mic out to ask people.
And lo and behold, everyone they talk to loves
Trump.
You've got to see this.
Speaker 2: Donald Trump's seventy fifth birthday
or James Clark went out to get birthday greetings.
Yeah.
What's going on, everyone?
James Klug here
Speaker 1: today.
If you're allergic to cringe, I would turn
away right now
Speaker 2: President Donald Trump's birthday.
And we're going to ask people in Huntington
Beach if they have a message for him.
Yeah, today is Donald Trump's birthday.
You have a message for him and a happy, happy,
happy birthday.
And I hope I see him back.
Do you have a message for him?
Yeah.
I wish him a great birthday.
I hope he's doing well.
I hope with all this public hate going on,
it's not getting to him and he's out there
killing on the golf course.
Yeah.
Speaker 1: Why is this so cringe?
Like, why is this so painful to watch?
Speaker 2: Tell me, why did Trump and I hope
he comes back in twenty twenty four.
Happy birthday, Mr. Trump.
And go out and shoot the low 70s today.
But happy birthday.
Happy birthday.
We love the guy is awesome.
Yeah.
Hawaii loves him.
He hugs the flag.
That's what I love about him is Donald Trump's
birthday.
You guys off a message from Love you, Donald
Trump.
Oh my gosh.
Our favorite news show,
Speaker 1: our favorite news show, Newsmax
is here.
What an incredible day.
Speaker 2: It's Donald Trump's birthday to
you.
Happy birthday.
Same issue.
Oh, my gosh.
Happy birthday, Donald.
Happy birthday.
I hope you're doing well.
I'm not going to wish you a happy birthday
because I think you're a jerk and I think
you should be in jail.
There you
Speaker 1: go.
Now that this woman I like this is a that's
a nice one of the laws
Speaker 2: that you broke.
What law specifically?
Of course, you would ask me that for the details.
For the details.
I don't I'm sorry.
I don't have any details.
It makes sense.
If you could get them one gift, what would
you get them come back?
I can't afford to buy them anything, but maybe
we could print out a photo of him hugging
the flag.
Raja, you could sign it.
He was signed to give it to me.
Yeah.
Speaker 1: So just, just, just painful guys.
I mean that is a segment that you know, I
can't in good countenance show you any more
of that.
So it's a I might end up at urgent care from
how hard I cringed Donald Trump now.
Seventy five.
And of course the only real practical consideration
is do we really think at seventy eight he's
going to run for president?
Maybe, maybe not.
We
will wait
and see.